welcome ladies and gentlemen it's a
pleasure to be with you tonight my name
is Bradley Devlin I'm the president of
the Berkeley College Republicans but
more importantly who's excited to see
our star-studded panel tonight featuring
Dave Rubin Heather McDonald and Steve
Simpson come on now thank you so much
for joining us for this event titled are
we killing free speech sponsored by the
I and Rand Institute
I find this inquisitive title and
dialogic nature of this event crucial to
the importance of what's happening on UC
Berkeley's campus and campuses all
across the country when the Berkeley
College Republicans travel oftentimes
conservatives and liberals alike ask how
does it feel to be the tip of the spear
in fighting for collegiate free speech
it truly is an empowering experience
what has gone on at UC Berkeley is
emblematic of what is happening to
conservative students all across the
country in the face of indoctrination
from regressive leftists that advocate
for safe spaces trigger warnings and
microaggressions we don't like those do
we my channel my inner Trump there it
felt really good these lone
conservatives who refuse to waver in
their principles continue to question
the status quo of hyper liberal campus
culture and tonight with three very
special guests we will continue to push
that envelope ladies and gentlemen it is
my distinguished honor to welcome Dave
Rubin of the Rubin report Heather
McDonald of the Manhattan Institute and
Steve Simpson of the Iran Institute
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
all right all right is my mic working my
mic working all right make some noise
people you are you are live on the
Internet so you represent all
Republicans right now all conservatives
all right leaning people that's a lot of
pressure for you guys are you up to it
one lady over there is up to it alright
that's what I like to see all right I'm
very excited to be here I I didn't
realize Berkeley until I did a little
research today you guys actually have
had some issues with free speech did not
I did not know that until today yeah you
almost burned the place down with Milo
which is any of you guys were setting
the fires was that probably not this
crew yeah I mean they imagine trying to
burn a place down over a bleached blonde
gay guy like that seem completely
ridiculous and then it cost what six
hundred thousand dollars right to secure
the campus for Ben Shapiro
that crazy Ben Shapiro a little Orthodox
Jew six hundred thousand dollars I feel
like he's like becoming like a sort of
alright fairy tale you know like the
Orthodox Jew behind the tree with facts
we're in trouble all right people this
is I'm excited to talk free speech with
you guys you guys know that it's it's
sort of it's sort of my gig I believe
that the the free speech issue
I truly believe is the issue of our time
for whatever you are studying at school
whatever you are learning about to learn
how to critically think to tolerate
other opinions to to engage people
without silencing them because there's a
lot of people out there these days that
want to silence you guys just in the
past week look what happened christina
hoff sommers I'm sure you guys all saw
that at Lewis & Clark law school your
own Brooke and sargon of akkad over in
the UK and Jordan Peterson at his event
somebody brought literally brought one
of those those things that the Mafia you
know those wires that the Mafia yeah
that the Mafia uses to choke people all
all ended violently I have a better
feeling about you guys here tonight
nobody has a weapon right where do we
know no weapons you would tell me now
right
that's how it works yeah anyway I truly
believe this is the most important issue
of our time and regardless of whether
I'll do a little quick poll and then
we'll start how many of you consider
yourself conservative how many or you
can make some noise instead of clapping
we've got the Internet people
how many how many libertarians hey you
were trying you were trying to get them
going
how many how many liberals okay
classical liberals that all right I'm
reading I'm reading the crowd
progressives how many progressives you
clapping for everything this man has
claps he has literally clap for
everything which you might be operating
like a progressive it's not you're
running for governor oh he's going for
everybody all right very good all right
well look whatever whatever your
political leanings are whatever you
identify as any of that stuff it really
is out the window as long as you will
defend free speech in my opinion it
doesn't matter there's such a beautiful
thing happening right now you know think
about this I'm sure many of you guys
watch my show you could take a guy of
the left like Sam Harris and you could
take a guy on the right like Ben Shapiro
these guys disagree on literally
everything literally everything from the
existence of God and the value of
religion to abortion to taxes to the
death penalty to everything and yet
they're allies now and they're allies
because of the same reasons you guys are
here right now because they want to
defend each other's ability to think and
ability to live in a free society it's
actually a pretty beautiful thing so for
everybody that thinks that all hell is
breaking loose in this country I
actually think there are some good
things happening I think you guys are
evidence of it and I think I've talked
enough so give me a round of applause
for that and then we're going to sit
down
all right so so Heather and Steve are
kind of right in the in the thick of the
free speech battle and Heather I'll
start with you because I spoke at
Claremont McKenna yeah at the beginning
of their they actually let me speak
there which is better than they did for
you actually you're not it's important I
guess well hold on I want to get out of
this one respectfully yes so you you
were supposed to speak and Claremont
McKenna a few a few months before I
spoke there I think in September of this
past year I think you were there in May
or June or so April April and give us
give us about a one-minute breakdown of
what happened what were you intending to
speak about and then and then what
happened well I was intending to speak
about the police in my book and saying
that in fact there is enormous
unrecognized support for the police in
high crime neighborhoods for that I've
been called a white supremacist fascist
homophobe as lama phob trans folk and
the the students at the various
claremont colleges were determined that
nobody should hear me speak so they
blockaded the venue of the Athenaeum
where as is supposed to speak i had to
be escorted in through a secret
passageway but there was nobody in the
auditorium and i spoke to an empty room
it was live-streamed like this event but
people were pounding on the plate-glass
windows during my talk and eventually
the security decided it was not safe and
i had to be escorted through the kitchen
an ignominious retreat yeah and and this
story of course is being played out all
the time on college campuses right now
it's it's why you guys are sitting here
right now to figure out how do you fight
the tide of this where do you think this
thing started Steve well I mean the the
pedigree of this kind of thing goes way
back right but but one of the places
that this this kind of thing of
protesting blocking people from speaking
one place it starts is actually here at
Berkeley now a lot of people look at
Berkeley as the beginning of the Free
Speech Movement on campus I think that's
a mistake
it's not necessarily to single out
Berkeley for criticism that's this is a
criticism you could launch it against a
lot of schools across the country but in
the 1960s there was the student uprising
and and this notion that taking over a
campus is equivalent to free speech or
using force against people is equivalent
to free speech or occupying other
people's property is or threatening
people and this has all happened in the
1960s people look at this as the birth
of free speech
I mean conflate speech with actions
speech with force and if you do that
people are going to respond to it and if
people really think that speech equals
protests that block others that occupy
other people's property that in any way
intimidate or harass or threaten people
they're gonna do the same thing in
Reverse they're gonna do the same thing
back now that's not necessarily to say
that that's what was going on
Claremont I think we've normalized the
idea that it's okay
to physically block people to physically
occupy their property and to attack them
as a form of free speech which is a
crazy idea if we as soon as we conflate
force and speech we lose speech and we
lose the ability to persuade each other
we lose the ability to reason with each
other and the only option at that point
is force and gang warfare but this is
one of the great ironies of thinking
that you know that that Berkeley is the
beginning of the Free Speech Movement I
would say it's the beginning of you know
if it continues it's the beginning of
the end of the Free Speech Movement but
it's certainly the beginning of the idea
that it's appropriate to block other
people from speaking or occupy their
property as a form of speech that is not
free speech that's a real mistake and
it's leading to a lot of what we're
seeing on campus let's let's test the
state of free speech at Berkeley at the
moment do this by applause so that the
the people that are watching online can
hear you how many of you have since
you've been at school here and I assume
most of you guys are students how many
of you have not said something either in
a class or to a friend or to a professor
because of you feared the repercussions
yeah I know it doesn't quite feel right
to applaud that but yeah
that's but that says it right there you
know it's funny I get only invited by
conservatives and libertarians and you
know some classical liberal groups I
always say I'll give the same speech to
the progressives or liberals if you know
them whatever you want to call them
Democrats lefties whatever if they'll
invite me they never do but I find all
the time I come and I talk to you guys
and it's like wow there I look I can
look out here there's a lot of diversity
out here the diversity that the left
loves I see a lot of different skin
colors here I'm sure there's some
different sexualities here and all sorts
of stuff but that doesn't matter what I
know matters and what you know matters
is diversity of thought how did we lose
that that caring for diversity of
thought on campus well I diagnosed this
as the free-speech problem is very
serious
it is as Steve says you either have
discourse or you have force and
discourse is what human beings developed
over millennia as an alternative to
brute force to get their way and it is a
thing of beauty and the pinnacle of
civilizational accomplishment so the the
current attacks on free speech are
extremely dangerous for our civilization
but I think the free speech problem is
just an epiphenomena of even more
serious problem which is the incessant
cultivation of a victim identity on the
part of an ever-growing group of
students and this is now the obsessive
goal of Education starting in grammar
school even where you have fifth graders
being indoctrinated into the whole
complex mythology of white privilege and
it continues in high school and
certainly in college there's now huge
bureaucracies and here at Berkeley you
have a 20 million dollar vice-chancellor
of equity diversity inclusion whose
purpose
is to continue hammering home the
preposterous point that to be a female
or person of color on the Berkeley
campus is to be under literal
existential threat and as long as that
remains the dominant belief that to be
in this ever growing number of victim
groups is to be a literal threat for
your life there used to have a banner on
campus of two students of color saying
allow people other than yourself to
exist that's modeling language but it's
meant literally as long as that remains
the dominant thinking it will follow
that non-conforming non-orthodox speech
is viewed not just as hate speech again
ridiculously but that hate speech is a
literal threat to one's existence and I
think we're not gonna solve the free
speech problem we can have faculty
signing all the petitions they want you
know if only more did so in favor of
free speech it's not going to matter as
long as this victimology ideology
remains the dominant one in higher
education well Steve as a straight white
man would you like to apologize to the
audience I'm middle-aged I mean is there
anything straight white man with all
women in my family so I apologize
alright how do we how do we reverse some
of this I mean we talked about this over
dinner and we all sort of were like wow
are we I like to think that I'm an
optimist at heart
Heather you said you're a pessimist
where do you I'm torn between you guys I
was I was on your side at first and now
now I'm generally an optimist but I have
but I'm an optimist that's realistic
about I'm optimistic because of the
potential of human beings I'm optimistic
because we can think we can't achieve
things look at the society we live in
today I mean this is one of so at one of
the great the big rebuttals to or one of
the things that people just ignore in
the whole victimology I just look at the
society we live in my god it's the most
advanced
freest greatest society in the history
of the world that I mean there's
something to be taken from that not just
that they're wrong to constantly be
playing victims and claim that they're
oppressed in a context in which they're
not oppressed but that human beings can
achieve unbelievable things that's a
great thing so I'm optimistic they're
human beings can also ruin great things
and I'm concerned about the future
because of the direction of this issue
and I think a lot of what Heather said I
I think they're deeper issues going on
which I don't want to we can talk about
them but I agree with the victimology
point I think that's a consequence of
even deeper philosophical convictions
and convictions about ideas that are
leading us to be victims to reject
rationality and speech to reject
individualism to claw on to groups and
and the rise of tribalism all of these
things are playing role but you're
absolutely right that this prosperity
that has been achieved through freedom
through trade through free markets is
stunning I mean every every item in this
room has been created by some guy who's
got a company or some woman in the in
the market chain it's extraordinary
but that doesn't persuade people and if
they can if a student on a campus like
this which is so beautiful I was in the
main library today
with these grand reading rooms and the
noble architecture and the the plants
the trees you've got around if they can
feel sorry for themselves and feel
oppressed at Berkeley I mean that's
preposterous they are leading they are
living a they're leading a delusion they
are they are completely unable to
perceive their privilege to be at a
place of learning where they should be
down on their knees every day saying
thank you for giving me this opportunity
to absorb human history languages
science you name it well that's why I
think is so fascinating because there's
such a disconnect between the reality of
the goodness of this country not to say
we don't have problems and and what this
sort of postmodern cultural Marxist
collectivist set of ideas whatever you
want to call it is
I mean you know I say this on the show
all the time but the essence of
prejudice is to prejudge I could look at
you guys right now and go okay brown guy
here white guy here girl here brown guy
there asian guy there white lady there
and that would assuming that I thought
that that meant I know what you think
that actually is prejudice and yet
somehow we're the ones that are
constantly being told that were bigots
and racists I assume most of you guys
again we'll do it by applause I know
it's weird to applause II think but most
of you I assume had been called all of
these these things and I need to figure
out I need to figure out some other way
to gauge reaction other than applauding
all the bad things we know this is the
way this thing will be clipped on
YouTube Rubin did a live stream they
were applauding bigotry and racism Lord
we stepped in it people somehow the
raising of the hand does you know hand
signal that won't go well either so jazz
hands all right we'll do jazz hands for
now and I see people we have a gay guy
you see you see gay people but I don't
judge him it's okay it's okay people how
do we how do we start turning the tide
here because when I was asking about
sort of whether you're whether you're an
optimist or a pessimist it's sort of
about now well okay a lot of us
recognize this all of these people they
recognize this the people watching at
home they recognize it but how do we
actually start turning this because it
can't just be on the students at
colleges Steve you have to go back to
fundamental ideas I mean you have to
challenge the fundamental mistakes that
people are making
let me just flag to them there's there's
widespread disdain for the idea that
human beings can think and can reason
their way out of problems they're just I
mean it's a weird thing to think that
that is true especially this is
everybody to attack reason you actually
I have to actually use reason it's it's
wacky it seems wacky but there's a whole
philosophical tradition of irrationalism
that it has been attacking reason for
generations it culminates I think in
post-modernism and a lot of the points
that you made before but there is real
disrespect for reason if you don't
respect reason if you don't respect the
fact that or believe that human beings
can make choices in their life
you're gonna look at them as just
they're they're you know they're
determined by other factors what's the
point of thinking what's the point of
speaking if you can't reach other people
because they're you know determined by
factors outside themselves then then
you're lost another point individualism
is on it under attack and in favor of
collectivism and tribalism this idea
that the individual should submit to the
group should sacrifice him or herself to
the group and that the group is somehow
all-powerful that's a an idea that's
been around for centuries but it's
actually on the rise somebody wrote in
the Washington Post the other day that
we should try socialism maybe socialism
is a good idea that you look at
Venezuela for God's sakes it was a well
written arm well they always say it's
never been trying yeah yeah I know but
right that's the thing but this is I
mean these are ideas that have been
around for a long time and if you follow
them to their logical consequences they
they have to lead to attacks on free
speech and free speech has to be blotted
out of existence if your obligation in
life is to just submit to the group who
are you to stand up and say I disagree
with the group this is why you have
censorship in totalitarian countries
yeah a knowledge of history would help I
mean what's so amazing is students don't
realize that traditionally free speech
helped the underdog Frederick Douglas in
1860 was going to be attending a meeting
in Boston to commemorate the one-year
death of the abolitionist John Brown and
the papers in New England had been
calling for silencing abolitionist
speech and a mob attacked this gathering
and there was fights that broke out you
know very much like an Tifa and
eventually Douglass and his fellow
orders were routed and and the several
days later he wrote an extraordinarily
moving another oration calling for free
speech in Boston and he said slavery
cannot survive free speech five years of
its exercise would break every chain and
every block and the historical ignorant
both about the power of free speech to
take down tyrants
the sort of charming naivete that they
think they're always going to be in
power are they really willing to give
Trump the ability to define hate speech
you know it's it works both ways
and you have to be if you believe that
you have the right to censor you have to
think what if the other side gets that
power and do I want to live under that
regime but people don't know the history
of how governments have used suppression
to silence opposition to silence
heterodox thought and they're also
extremely naive about their own
precarious one hopes hold on power
yeah it's partly why I feel like this is
happening all over the West right now I
get emails literally from I mean
virtually every country on earth you
know and we bounced around the globe
from France and Australia and Mexico and
and China and Japan and every literally
Iraq from Saudi Arabia at places that
don't have freedom in the places that do
but the most alarming ones I get
actually are from the Western countries
it's from people that are in France and
that are in Belgium and Eastern Europe
which is having all sorts of problems
with this you guys think that part of
this is actually the success of the West
I mean it's like as you alluded to
earlier we could look out here these are
students at one of the most incredible
schools in the entire country
who have everything at their fingertips
you come from different things some of
you are gonna make great successes and
some of you are going to be miserable
failures hate to tell ya I could point
it a couple of you now it's pretty
obvious but no just kidding that guy
looked at his friend he was like yo dude
but that part of what's happening here
is it's the success of the West I think
that all of these countries they got to
a certain point not that it was perfect
not that there aren't racist not that
there aren't bigots and all of those
things which will always exist but that
a certain amount of freedom started
turning on itself and I think that
that's what we're seeing here do you
think that's a fair assessment I mean I
wouldn't quite put it that way I don't
blame the read them for that but yeah
but I think that the issue I mean that's
part of the it's it's easy to take
things for granted when you're as rich
as we are you know I tell my kids this
every day you have no idea what it's
like to even have a job why are we you
know complaining about the fact that you
don't get to drive the exact car that
you want today but it's hard for to
communicate that to young people but I
don't think it's the fundamental issue I
think the fundamental issue is that the
West when you're referring to the West
and I would think about it more as
America and the pinnacle of freedom and
I don't think people really have ever
understood what freedom really has to be
grounded on and they haven't understood
consistently and we haven't had the real
defense of freedom that we that we need
and it's it's been flawed I mean the
founders were great men they did many
great things and they were I think
political geniuses but they there were
flaws in in you know their thinking
about the founding of America and there
are flaws in our views of free speech
today there's all kinds of problems with
our views of free speech I mentioned
earlier but the idea of conflating force
with speech that happens all over the
place people don't understand the role
of property rights in free speech and
that you know your your free speech
basically ends at somebody else's
property you do not have the right to
speak on someone else's property if we
conflate that we cause all kinds of
conflict and then you you actually plant
the seeds of people thinking it actually
does make sense for me to fight back if
I'm forced to have to deal with this if
if it's okay to take over somebody
else's property if it's okay to you know
come into my living room let's say or
take over my company or my school and
I'm and I'm really conflating force and
speech and many other things then I
think people will start to see free
speech as a flawed impractical concept
and and they will fight back against it
so some of this makes sense it's not to
excuse the people who are doing it but I
think a lot of what we're seeing in the
attacks on free speech and just freedom
in general there's a kind of logic to it
if you accept the flawed views that a
lot of people have it does make some
logical sense to be opposed to free
speech because you think it really is a
threat again that's not to defend that
the people but I do think though I agree
with Dave that prosperity has bred a
certain over ripeness a certain
decadence and and I would Steve you and
I probably disagree about this because
of emphasis on tradition first
complete individual rights but I would
say that with the 50s we had something
for the first time in human history ever
which is adolescents with buying power
never before had there been a society so
prosperous that 14 year olds 15 year
olds themselves could now control enough
spending power that you had capitalism
catering to their tastes and this gave
rise to the counterculture and the youth
revolution which you know you may say
has benefits but I would say that some
of the loss of parental authority and
the rise of an adolescent culture the
the sex drugs and rock and roll of a
immediate personal gratification and
wish fulfillment has not worked out
ideally I think we've lost something you
know to be honest and that was because
capitalism has been so fantastically
successful that now you have companies
that are going over the heads of parents
and marketing directly to kids and their
their tastes in entertainment in music
dominate and that's that's a very
unusual and unprecedented situation for
a human civilization and some of those
adolescent values I think are now quite
dominant and and even the victimology
and in terms of the maudlin narcissism
of people you know a college student
saying like at Brown the students that
went and met with the Provost and said
please exempt us from traditional
academic requirements like going to
class and taking exams because we're
trying so hard to stay alive at Brown as
students of color I mean come on these
are be embarrassed to say something like
that but that's sort of adolescent
self-pity is now part of our culture
yeah and it's interesting to me how this
stuff just bleeds through everything and
that there's sort of no end to this
movement so one of the things that when
Steve and I have done a few of these
before we've talked about is I'm sure
you guys remember on
inauguration day when that guy punched
Richard Spencer the the alright guy and
now I I think his ideas are odious
America is not a white country it's that
that's actually the reverse of what the
the founders intended we are a
multicultural society we're a melting
pot but suddenly I saw all of these
people you know the whole blue cheque
Twitterati Brigade defend you know not
only defending the the guy who punched
him but saying yeah you've got to get
out there and punch Nazis and then it's
like I know you've you've all seen this
where the this definition of what is a
Nazi who is alt right where this just
keeps expanding keeps expanding and then
it's like alright well if you can punch
a Nazi well now let's just start
labeling everyone Nazis and you know can
you can you burn down a Nazis house can
you break into his car what if his
wife's in the house what about the kid
so we're creating something that
actually is just spreading sort of it to
me it seems like this is spreading like
a virus because it's like this stuff
this idea of identity politics and the
oppression Olympics and all this stuff
it's very easy to get you know you can
catch it really easy it's very easy to
think ever you look around and
everyone's racist and everyone's evil
and I'm oppressed and I'm a victim it's
not that easy to do what I think you
guys are doing which is go alright I got
to make something of myself and I got to
do something in this world that that's a
lot harder so is that look at that guy
you see he heard something brilliant he
slowly clapped until the rest of you but
I can clap do because freedom is good it
takes a little while I get it thank you
for that well could someone explain why
anti-fog gets to call itself anti-shah
who's the one that's engaging in fascist
proto-fascist behavior i mean i don't
want to get too hysterical here and you
know become exaggerating what's going on
but we're not obviously a fascist state
that would be I don't want to adopt
their tactics but by and large they're
the ones that are breaking windows and
trying to silence speak why why can they
get away with this it's totally bizarre
I guess if they just call themselves
father
it doesn't sound that good yeah I mean
that's well you guys must see a lot of
them around here and it's like do any of
them make a coherent argument I mean do
you ever where do you sit down with
these people I mean I guess they don't
go to Starbucks that's capitalist where
can you sit with these people you know
we'll hold it will hold it to the QA but
I do want to hear your thoughts go ahead
real quick yeah
forceful tolerance I like that yeah I
mean that that really is it and that's
partly what we're up against and what's
interesting is so many it's not just the
students I mean again I think
unfortunately you guys in college right
now you get a bad rap because of this
smaller this small group of people but
it's the it's the professor's it's the
administrators I get emails every day
from people at school saying my teacher
you know I said something about the
gender pay gap and my teacher called me
racist I mean really legitimately crazy
things so it's like we have to really
rethink all of these institutions yeah I
mean I'm sort of starting to be in favor
of homeschooling for college you know do
you guys were last generation and then
everybody's gonna get private tutors and
do the Grand Tour in Europe or something
I don't know is it because it's we're
gonna reach a tipping point when older
faculty retire and now the younger ones
are themselves the product of the
victimology University and that that
that gets to be a worrisome point of how
you break the monopoly hold of a world
view that I think is demonstrably false
it is just demonstrably false that there
is institutional racism on an American
college campus the opposite is the case
there is not a single faculty search
where the primary goal is to interview
and ideally hire either females or
underrepresented minorities that is
happening in the STEM fields in the
humanities and the social sciences and
in most college admissions the goal is
maximal diversity defined as you say by
these superficial
characteristics of melanin and the
schools like you see is twisting itself
into knots to get around the
constitutional ban on racial preferences
so it's it's the exact opposite these
are the most tolerant institutions in
human history that value precisely the
traits that can still get you stoned to
death elsewhere and yet people insist on
on viewing the college campus as a place
of maximal oppression it's just it's
astounding Steve do you think that
technology is part of the answer here I
mean all of these guys know about us
because of YouTube and Twitter and
Facebook things you know companies that
have major problems that are actually
completely related to free speech but
you have access now to great minds
online that you didn't have access to
before I mean just some of the people
that I get to sit with on any given week
I mean I'm sitting with the Weinstein
brothers and with Jordan Peterson and
Ben and Sam and all of these guys and
it's like man if you're a college
student and you're you're you know just
crushed under this nonsense which is not
learning it's it's the reverse of
learning you can actually go out there
and for free you know be able to learn
from some pretty great people yeah I
mean it's definitely part of the
solution it's not a complete solution
because you have to have good ideas too
you know technology disseminates the
ideas and that's that's great and we can
I you know the attacks on social media
today even frankly I mean there's a lot
wrong with Google but the attacks on
Google the attacks on YouTube I think
they're all they're all really badly
mistaken now it doesn't mean that there
aren't great things to criticize and we
can talk about that we were talking
about it was loads to criticize about
YouTube Google even Facebook although I
think Facebook is better but the idea
that somehow the problem here is
technology because we you know we can
you can disseminate bad ideas through
technology it's really badly mistaken
there I mean you can just as easily
disseminate good ideas through
technology and frankly it's easier now
to debunk fake news than probably it
ever has been in history yeah it's also
easier to disseminate fake
News but I mean you can learn your we
have access to more information today
than I think anybody has ever had access
to before and in history now that
doesn't help if people aren't able or
willing to use the information so
there's an education issue there's an
issue of you know just having the right
ideas and knowing how to think people
have to be able to think and there's a I
mean there's a huge problems with our
education we are not teaching people how
to think we're not teaching them respect
for reason we're not teaching them
respect for free speech so technology
won't solve it it's a wonderful tool to
help solve the problem but we still need
better ideas and we need better better
thinking well I you know critical
thinking is a watchword of the
progressive education establishment and
of course what they mean by it is like
deconstructing commercials to show the
you know the hidden evil capitalism
behind it but I actually disagree with
that I don't I don't think the goal of
education is critical thinking I
actually don't even think that the goal
of education is debate I think the goal
of education is to cram as much
knowledge into the empty noggins of
students including myself which it was
not crammed into as possible and debate
is part of that but there's there's vast
fields of knowledge for which the
dialogic model of well debating opinion
is simply irrelevant it doesn't make
sense to say well I have an opinion
about the second law of thermodynamics
but I'm willing to listen to yours or I
have an opinion about the spread of
civilization in the early Mediterranean
or I have an opinion about German cases
I think that the problem is not lack of
critical thinking the problem is the
lack of knowledge and knowledge of thank
you but agree knowledge of our history
its flaws and its strengths the fact
that we have created a stable society
out of what has been always usually
brute force and chaos that we've created
works of extraordinary beauty whether
it's Mozart
or Beethoven or Milton or Shakespeare
this should be understood and
appreciated and and the history that got
us here if people don't know that I
don't think any amount of critical
thinking will will suffice so I
definitely agree that you have to have
knowledge but it's both of those things
I don't think you can acquire knowledge
without thinking and understanding how
how people learn and how people think so
I don't mean to suggest it's critical
thinking or knowledge and I've gone the
critical thinking sight is both and
you're right absolutely people need
knowledge but you need you need the
ability to understand how human beings
learn and and and how to teach people
and so you know I think it's both of
those things and and I definitely agree
with you but but you learn their
thinking by absorb yeah I wish them yes
and well but I can teach it separately I
I think that's right I definitely think
you're right about that but why ask
yourselves why is it that people think
so your point about the debating you
know about the idea that everything
should be subject to a debate debating
is the best way of learning I agree with
you wholeheartedly it's totally wrong
and today I mean this is part of though
I think we have to face the fact that
oftentimes when we hear people talking
about free speech they're always saying
what we need is more debate we need more
intellectual diversity not really I mean
the intellectual diversity in itself is
not a thing it's not good to say well we
want intellectual diversity so we got to
hire some racists and hire some
communists and hire some people who you
know deny physics the flat earthers the
people who deny evolution that come it's
like no that's not that's not what it
means and so if we hold out an idea like
diversity of thought just as a floating
abstraction doesn't mean anything but
people do then think oh we just need
that the solution to the education
crisis or the fact that people aren't
learning those would just throw a couple
other professors in there who have a
diversity of thought that doesn't teach
anybody anything they need to be
discriminating they need to actually
figure out what knowledge is true and
and how to even think about that another
idea I think that that I think we should
challenge that it's what I would call a
package deal is the idea of tolerance
that we should just tolerate every idea
and this I think leads people to be
repelled by free speech and the
I always have to tolerate anything you
shouldn't tolerate every idea and the
same way you should be discriminating
about what you learn I mean as a take a
benign example or a relatively benign
example if I were in biology class and
they marched in the intelligent design
guy the creationist and said just
tolerate this guy because his views are
just as good as Brett Weinstein's for
instance no that's nonsense I'm say
[ __ ] yeah we should it's [ __ ]
but but it doesn't mean you attack the
guy right yeah you don't attack him you
say I don't buy this this is nonsense
I'm gonna criticize this prison if if
this is really what this school is all
about I'm out of here I want to walk I'm
gonna vote with my feet we have to
understand that thinking reasoning
speaking involves not just saying things
to people involves sometimes taking
action and sometimes saying what you are
teaching me is crap I don't want
anything or I think your ideas are evil
I'm not going to support those ideas I'm
adding we have to have freedom of
association we have to have freedom of
movement you know freedom of action and
freedom of speech so there's an
interesting component here that that
Steve kind of touched on which is the
technological side of it how many of you
actually believe that that YouTube
Google all that all the social media
companies are now an active threat to
free speech yeah I mean that that that
is a lot that is a huge problem right
now and it's there's a huge debate
obviously on in the YouTube community
about what do you do about this and
there's organizations run by a guy who I
love Dennis Prager and they're involved
in a lawsuit right now my my libertarian
side says that getting the government
involved is never the answer I know
Steve you're you're kind of where I'm at
with that but it's interesting I think
there's a compelling this is an
interesting case where I think there's
somewhat of a compelling argument that
Google controls so much information so
much of the tubes the pipes that we get
this stuff through so much of our
ability to communicate that perhaps
there's something unique here I haven't
been fully sold on that but I'm curious
what what you think about that Heather
you're asking the wrong person as far as
the tech possibilities here well
chronically broad early if the
government should be involved in this
well you know what we've got now is not
working so I don't know I can't I have
no faith it would be any better say
under you know an administration call it
the Obama administration just once a
heck that that shares the same
victimology ideology would they do
anything different than Google they may
have the exact same views that Dennis
I'm my to Dennis Prager videos have been
taken off the web went on on the
diversity bureaucracy and campuses and
the other on the the war on cops and and
the black lives matter movement so I
don't know I think you mean unrestricted
right but it's very hard to get to yeah
but I you know I think what we've seen
we've had this extraordinary window into
the thinking at Google and it should
scare all of us it's it turns out that
it's no accident what the political
leanings are of how they categorized
speech as unfit for juvenile consumption
because they are now a mirror image of
the type of narrow thinking that you're
experiencing on colleges it's it's
extraordinary this lawsuit that was
filed against Google has pulled out
screenshots of some of the internal
messaging and they're all talking about
microaggressions and punching Nazis and
and absolutely demonizing white males
and the thing that's most scary is not
only that Google decided that it could
fire somebody from daring to challenge
the feminist explanation for why there's
not gender parity in tech which is that
there's widespread discrimination
against females and and damar said well
there may also be career preferences
that come into play and sir
on average dispositions between males
and females with regards to abstract
work versus people centered work he's
again he's talking about averages not
any individual male or female
but the actions of Google in firing day
more were upheld by a associate general
counsel of the National Labor Relations
Board who declared that to challenge the
feminist explanation of of why there's
not gender parity and to say that there
may be certain biological differences
between males and females that
constitutes sexual harassment and
discrimination at such a pernicious
level that an employee can be fired that
means that anybody in an academic
science department working on
evolutionary biology or psychology or
economics I know a female economist who
has done research and found that across
every culture that's ever been whether
it's hunter-gatherers or our culture men
are more competitive all those people
can be fired for sexual harassment so
science now is a fireable offense
because it violates feminist ideology
that is a very very worrisome situation
okay
can I just yeah social media issue I
won't take too much time
other than says everybody who clapped
for the proposition that social media is
a trap or a threat you're all wrong
now you're probably nice people and
everything but absolutely wrong you're
all fascists no but I will say this this
is a really grave error this is this is
what I was talking about before people
don't understand free speech there that
it's not I don't think it's possible for
social media it makes no sense to say
social media is a threat to free speech
that's like saying all of us talking and
what we'll get to questions later all of
us talking and trading our views and
just disseminating information is it's
it's itself a threat to free speech it's
like saying free speech is a threat to
free speech it doesn't make any sense
that doesn't mean that everything that
Facebook and
all of the various social media
companies do is perfect I mean I agree
with you what Google did today more
really is atrocious and my view if I
mean we need to accept the the day more
complaint as true all the way they have
emails in there I mean there's really
atrocious behavior I think it seems to
me that they fired him because he did
exactly what they want him to do he
expressed his views now I think there's
a lot wrong with his views although he
would he expressed them you know
intelligently exactly the way you would
want a person to do that and they and
they can demand I think that's really
bad news but it doesn't make Google
equivalent to a censor Google cannot
censor your speech Facebook cannot
censor your speech YouTube cannot censor
your speech they can say I don't want
you to speak on my platform my platform
I created it you don't get to speak on
here it can be stupid it can be
disagreeable
they can be wrong about that I'm like I
know you all a lot of your videos are
restricted and I think it's stupid I
criticize them don't get me wrong but
the the issue here is they created this
platform it is their platform it is not
your platform you do not have a right to
have a video on well guy in the cake
later but this is a good example get you
if you can't hold on buddy buddy buddy
yeah buddy hang tight hang tight we'll
get you we'll get you the cutie we'll
get you no problem my friend my friend
respect yeah respect everybody else here
we'll get you I promise
hang tight no I got your ooh show we got
it yeah I understand the issue of
California well I don't want to give him
the legal issues it's too big a
discussion but the point is that it's
all wrong I'll just put it that way
they're wrong Prager his lawsuit I'm I
could even be sympathetic to it they are
definitely wrong and it's crackers in my
view for a conservative to be suing a
private company under by invoking law
written by the most leftist court in the
whole goddamn country that the
California Supreme Court decisions he's
relying on our crap they are totally
wrong and and I don't give a rat's ass
how many lawyers line
to tell me oh this is this is president
and this is what the law says they're
all wrong I mean the right that it's
precedent they are wrong that it's good
we could we could complain about law all
the damn time in this country constantly
the fact that a court issues a damn
decision that that says something crazy
or even the fact that a court issues a
decision doesn't make it right
we should criticize the law constantly
just like we should criticize what
Google is doing so don't tell me about
what the what the law says I don't care
what the California Supreme Court said
they are definitely wrong what that what
they have basically done is said that a
private company is now a public forum
once you do that free speech is over
it's gone you cannot have free speech if
you don't have public or private
property
absolutely positively I mean that's the
same thing as saying that that when when
the university reserves this space for
us to speak it's a free-for-all and if
we don't let everybody speak at once
that's somehow a violation of their
right to free speech that is totally
wrong but it's public utility that do
they have a monopoly of transportation
in which case can it be regulated so
we're getting it I mean I don't want to
get too far at all I would say is this
public utilities are a mistake but but
the private companies do not exercise
the same kind of power that governments
do we and if we conflate that free
speech is done and all of freedom is
done to quickly put a button on this you
guys have invited Dennis Prager here
next week right then if Dennis is a
great guy and I and I hope that you'll
ask him these very questions because
this is what it's all about you've got
principled people on both sides who both
defend freedom I don't know many guys
that defend freedom or more than Dennis
and more than you Steve that have a
different approach on this one and
perhaps this is a unique case because of
the utility argument and all those
things we can't fully resolve that here
I do want to add one other thing and
then I want to jump to your questions
cuz I can sense there are a few
questions that you might have for us
that one of one of the most nefarious
things that that Google did in the last
week that many of you probably saw was
that they there was this internal memo
about how they weren't gonna hire male
Asian or white male engineers I mean
think about that there are some of you
here that are aging should you be
discriminated against for working hard
and going to school and you know
hopefully you're trying to get the job
that you deserve and all that so
actually we're
flipping logic on its head the more we
allow this faux diversity that's what it
is this is not real diversity this is
faux diversity and eventually it will
come come eat itself on that note I
think we should oh man we're going to
Steve and I were discussing in one sense
both Steve and I would sort of say if
Google wants to destroy its own
competitiveness by by completely
self-destructive hiring criteria that
are irrelevant I mean it's just
irrelevant what somebody's race or
gender is they should be hiring the best
possible engineers let that's their
prerogative what I worry about is that
China is not yet infested by this and I
think if Trump wants to help America
compete
he should airlift several plane loads of
gender feminists theorists of China
Beijing University drop them down and
let them do their work but as long as
they're free of this we're doomed we are
I mean you know at some maksim outside
the box thinking right there take him
from Berkeley you've got I can name a
few professors that I think could be
helpful to Beijing if we want to have
trade wars going on that's a bad idea we
tell them we're teaching like the
greatest diversity class of all time
they show up and then we airlift them to
China and yeah good luck guys all right
well give these guys a round of applause
thank you guys for for coming out